welcome back to the rockstars this is a
breakdown of the new trailer for Blue
Beetle the DC Superhero Movie coming
this August I'm Eric Voss here with
Wikileaks co-host and friend of the
channel Hector Navarro yay I'm here and
just like we said right before we
started rolling doing it Eric we are
here man
we are gonna break down this trailer
frame by frame for all of the Easter
eggs and visual details that you might
have missed so let's get started excuse
me Mr Reyes finished scraping the gum
off that lounger or what all right okay
the trailer opens with Jaime Reyes sholo
Marie duenia with his sister Milagros de
Lisa Escobedo working at this mansion
and we get this great fake outwear for a
moment it seems like Jaime is like he's
a Bruce Wayne level billionaire but his
whole suit is the uniform of the
cleaning staff it's similar to the gag
we saw in Shang Chi that trailer where
they made it seem like it was chunky in
the sports car but he's actually the
ballet but you know what highway still
looks baller I love this camera swooping
like he's alone on the deck there's no
other staff visible in this shot it just
shows how his reality truly is a symptom
of his imagination his ambition he
didn't need the suit this guy already
sees the world the way he wants it to be
very relatable Eric very relatable and
just to give you all a bit of background
on who this character is Jaime Reyes was
created by writers Keith Giffin and John
Rogers and artist Coley Hamner and he
made his first appearance in the comics
in 2006 in the third issue of the
universe shattering Infinite Crisis
mini-series two issues later in the same
series Jaime first appeared as the Blue
Beetle this was all to set up his new
ongoing Series where Jaime would take
the stage as the title superhero Jaime
is also not the first character to take
on the mantle of the Blue Beetle just
like Green Lantern the Blue Beetle
Mythos has a long history that dates
back to the Golden Age of comics but
we're gonna get more into that in a
little bit Yeah and back in the trailer
we see that a plane is landing over the
beach in Palmyra City it's a fictional
city in the DC Universe like Gotham
Metropolis or Central City but in the
comics Jaime spends most of his time in
El Paso Texas before you know he said
that he's going to move on to Palmyra
City for the summer after his graduation
but they did shoot a lot of this in El
Paso with these Beach shots I believe
were shot in Puerto Rico but a beach by
the airport does remind us a lot of
Miami Beach where planes land at M.I.A
going right over the beach and every
time I laid it and I am like oh cool I
can't wait to hang out here but it's
like no no you're going to connect to
Jacksonville Florida have fun idiot
welcome to Miami bye Eric
adios Miami but the jet has this awesome
colorful Underside and it might just be
me seeing this but there are spots that
look like eyes similar to the pattern
that you see on some beetles that are
designed to ward off Predators who see
the spots and think that they're the
eyes of a large animal even the planes
in this universe are getting on this
Beetle craze absolutely it's a very
colorful Universe now thankfully Jaime
and his sister sit on their rooftop
looking at Palmera City towering on the
horizon where Jaime says that everything
feels so Out Of Reach which might be a
clever reference to the Blue Beetle lore
or it might be us looking too much into
things as per usual and I like how
production designer John Billington has
made they it got the mermetropolis in
its own right it's filled with vibrant
Hues added with these neon lights but
the same colors we see covering the
homes in high mate's neighborhood which
might be called the keys which is the
same as the oldest part of Palmyra City
in the comics but all these colors are
done with paint here they don't need the
bright neon lights they just do it the
way everyone else does now throughout
this film one feels like Jaime could be
destined to wear this suit and see
through its eyepiece it's just based off
the color of the world as it is in the
First Act and I like how you can just
make out ace chemicals over there on the
left side hopefully the Palmera branch
of ace chemicals covers its chemical
bats uh-oh villains be falling into bats
you gotta watch where you fall man
so the tallest purple skyscraper is cord
plaza where Jaime shows up for an
interview supported by his whole family
Jaime has to wear his school Blazer or
something I'm sure he feels nervous
about but he looks great hire this man
cord hire this man that's right give him
a chance I like how this upward looking
shot from the ground doesn't even show
the tower's full height compared to the
wide shot that we saw before it gives
this building's architecture a menacing
deceptive quality oh absolutely and the
name cord comes from Ted cord who
debuted not in DC Comics but in Charlton
comics in 1966 and was the previous
possessor of the Scarab but never
himself had super powers instead grad
student Ted cord would use His Brilliant
inventions to fight crime including his
awesome v-toll that's vertical takeoff
and Landing vehicle called Bug later in
1983 DC Comics would acquire the
Charlton Comics cast of characters like
Captain Adam Nightshade the question
Peacemaker who's now played by John Cena
in the DC EU and of course Blue Beetle
Ted cord all of these characters were
originally pitched to DC in the 80s to
be used by writer Alan Moore in a new
comic miniseries but DC said they had
other plans for the Charlton crew so
Moore co-created new characters with
Dave Gibbons for their groundbreaking
Watchman series Loosely based on the
Charlton superheroes like Night Owl who
was based on Ted Court Blue Beetle
interesting history there but here
instead of Ted Court in this movie we
are getting the character's sister in
the comics Victoria cord played by Susan
Sarandon Victoria is the CEO of cord
Industries and was introduced in Blue
Beetle graduation day issue number two
which just came out in February of this
year by writer Josh Trujillo an artist
Adrian Gutierrez Victoria is going to be
we assume in this movie kind of a
corporate villain in the vein of Lex
Luthor now does this mean we're gonna
get a tease for where Ted cord could be
in the DC EU
I don't know we've been hearing rumors
that it's going to be Ted lasso that'd
be a little too on the nose I think the
color coding of cord Plaza is strict
like notice every employee has to wear
purple tones we see lavender ties and
blouses Blazers skirts really lean into
that colorful almost Speed Racer like
saturation of this world even the
security guards chasing Jenny have
purple K logos absolutely definitely
reminds me of Royalton Industries in the
movie Speed Racer with all that purple
but Jenny it seems has stolen the Scarab
from Victoria cord and handed it off to
Jaime in this burger carton big belly
Burger a fast food chain from the DC
Comics technically a subsidiary of
lexcorp the logo is based on the Bob's
Big Boy Burger Chef now the Scarab
latches onto Jaime's face and we get 50
seconds of pure horror they did not need
to go this hard actor it is so wild so
we're gonna break this down frame by
frame to point out all the little horror
parallels yes and I know this was your
favorite part Eric so I know you're
enjoying this very very much but the
face latch is totally an alien xenomorph
face hugger and George Lopez plays Uncle
Rudy with the best hair and goatee I've
ever seen and he gets Zapped across the
room showing his shorts and red high
tops once the comic relief goes down you
know there's nothing left but unfiltered
Gore yep no wonder crack jokes we're
just all here to scream from here
forward the exoskeleton bulges out of
his back and burns through his sweater
everyone is screaming as he has flown up
to the ceiling just like a John
Carpenter's The Thing during that
horrifying blood test scene and Jaime's
body initially Falls lip making him look
briefly as a corpse the acid covers his
hand and burns off his clothes as Jaime
screams it drips off look at those shoes
they're dripping the fluid looks like
the discharge some beetles are known to
excrete as a defense mechanism and
there's your animal fun fact my face
cream's in pain as the sludge is
covering his head and his eyes and his
nose his freaking teeth and I think the
creepiest reference Hector that I think
is actually happening here is from
another DC movie Superman 3 when that
supercomputer becomes self-aware and it
in snares Vera transforming her into
that Cyborg and she screams as her skin
is being covered in wires and metal
plating I hate it I'm sorry everyone for
the nightmares here but James Gunn
promised Gods and Monsters that's what
DC is yeah that's exactly what DC is
Jaime is now looking up at his family
through a heads-up display with alien
riding we don't have any basis for which
to translate this but I like how on the
lower right more text Data Scrolls
upward as the suit gathers Intel on its
surroundings everything in his view has
been rendered in a fluid watercolor
two-dimensional interface like animation
or the panel of a comic the Scarab voice
is the one thing we're missing here
nothing against the actress chosen but
they're going for something robotic
closer to Alexa or Siri and I think we
all like that little stinker they had
voicing the Scarab in Young Justice
the Scarab that we're hearing is named
Kaji da in the comics and it's later
revealed to be a super Advanced weapon
created by the alien species called The
Reach and that was what that reference
was from maybe earlier in the trailer
the Scara first landed on Earth in
ancient Egypt and it was accidentally
imbued with magical powers it has its
own interesting Comics history but
basically it was entombed in Egypt for
thousands of years until it was found by
an archaeologist character that we're
going to talk about later but back to
the trailer it's cool to see that the
blue Scarab shell not only taking over
his entire body but just really pieces
of it like armor leaving the rest of him
exposed with this kind of Under Armor
layer colored brown or mauve for
contrast to the blue it's like the
staining from the sludge and so this way
when he talks his jaw actually moves
it's closer to Deadpool than to Iron Man
flexibility Allowed by that lower layer
and it allows the character of Blue
Beetle to emote more of a personality
when he is suited up and then we see the
Beetle wings detach into rocket boosters
and blast them through the roof and just
listen to this section here
[Music]
oh
re-entry systems ready yes Jaime suit
takes them into space and we love that
all you hear is Jaime's own voice and
his AI talking back to him this suits
thrusters do not make any sound because
in space no one can hear Jaime's great I
know you would love to say that Eric I
knew it I knew you're gonna love to say
that now April is Earth month which
makes it the perfect time to consider
the impact the choices you make have on
the planet we all have to share one easy
way to reduce your waste and impact is
to use hellofresh hellofresh is an
amazing meal delivery service with 40
recipes and over 100 season only
convenience items to choose from each
week with so much variety there are
options for everyone and every lifestyle
and it doesn't matter whether or not
you're an Iron Chef hellofresh's
foolproof recipes arrive
pre-proportioned and easy to prepare in
just a few steps hellofresh's
pre-proportioned ingredients cut down on
your food waste by at least 23 compared
to grocery shopping besides hellofresh
it's cheaper than grocery shopping and
25 cheaper than takeout on average hello
fresh meals have a 31 lower carbon
footprint than the same meals made from
supermarketing ingredients plus nearly
all hello fresh packaging materials are
curbside recyclable in most areas of the
United States plus it tastes great this
week I got some pork tenderloin the
apricot Dijon mustard sauce
tenderloin more like tender
I hate myself so to get started go to
hellofresh.com and use the code
Rockstar's 50 for 50 off plus your first
box ships free once again that's
h-e-l-l-o-f-r-e-s-h.com and get 50 using
the code rockstars50 next we see the
family along with Jenny entering what is
probably a high security cord facility
as she explains what the Scarab is
Milagros wears a similar Auto Body Shop
shirt as Uncle Rudy with Reyes on the
label making this the family business
and while sitting at the Reyes family
dinner table Jenny explains how the
Scarab works or doesn't work while we
see it in action protecting Jaime from
an oncoming bus reminiscent again of
that great sequence in chongqi in the
legend of the 10 Rings hopefully no one
was hurt on that bus it also reminds us
of the way Doctor Strange bisected a bus
with magic in Multiverse of Madness
leave public transportation Alone movies
superhero movies specifically and in his
Scarab Vision that's that's what I'm
gonna call it now there we go new rock
stars right there
but as as he looks at the bus it
identifies several passengers one by one
and yellow on the left side it includes
this guy standing with a hat and the
woman seated in front of him who I think
is the baby in her lap so it's like the
Scarab is identifying don't hurt these
people there are people here here and
here here just be careful just go down
the middle also that meter bar on the
right has a few nodes reduced from the
shot of the family before maybe this is
like the suit's health or structural
Integrity meter let's figure it out
we'll figure out that very very video
game specific detail another great
detail here is that time seems to be
slowing down for Jaime either through
the scarabs abilities or just the
stylization of the movie itself but
during this moment we see Blue Beetle
putting his hand up to his mouth in
shock kind of like when Deadpool
sarcastically does the same thing but
back to the bad guy Susan Sarandon's
Victoria cord monologuing about how the
Scarab chose Jaime but that it belongs
to me we wonder if there will be any
mention of how the Scarab may have
belonged to Ted cord but like in the
comics 10 could never really get it to
work for him which is why he relied on
his own Tech and gadgets and then we see
a tower of Red Energy powered batteries
similar to the human batteries in The
Matrix movies line up a tower and power
something up perhaps a Victoria cord
version of the Blue Beetle suit maybe a
red beetle even I don't know I feel like
we're just spitballing and writing a
generic superhero movie here I don't
know Eric what do you think it does
sound possible that could be where it's
going it is just hard to make out what
this is I like that matrix comparison
there because it did remind me a lot of
those human Farms but at the bottom of
the frame there is an open elevator door
with a few people in there so I think
one of them might be Jenny it's hard to
tell but maybe we're looking at Victoria
cord's attempts to replicate or just
siphon the scarab's energy source but
then there's also an interesting shot of
the Scarab floating in a nebulous energy
field kind of seems like it's something
part of a montage explaining the scarabs
origin maybe we're gonna find out how it
was an enemy the antagonist of the Green
Lantern Court I'm gonna tie in the Green
Lantern Corps into this movie I think
that'd be an extreme way to go that
could be very true underpinning that
feeling of unease that we feel we see
highly Advanced drones the staple of any
tech-based movie Bad Guy of the past 10
years as the Reyes family gets caught in
the Crosshair of their SWAT armor
wearing security Force probably a part
of cord that is looking for Jaime and
his alien suit and a great shot of one
of the villains of the film The Very
Michael K vulture looking Raul Max
Trujillo as Kara packs the
indestructible man a Blue Beetle super
villain who in the comics accidentally
has his mind transferred into the body
of a robot so it should be a pretty good
fight I think Kara Pax is saying that
the love Jaime feels for his family
makes him weak and we all know how
that's gonna turn out for the bad guy
okay we all saw Spider-Man into the
spider-verse hey hey
now there are some great shots of Blue
Beetle infiltrating some underground bad
guy complex might be that one in the
island that we see that the bug flying
towards he's kicking ass and kicking ass
like he flips his Soldier while the guy
is still there and then he kicks him it
gets the wall and I just gotta hand it
to the whole suit design the the
costuming team to make this suit light
up blue so that we could see it so well
even in his Darkly lit red Hue tunnel it
all just stands out and Pops off the
screen so beautifully to make every hit
count absolutely very very smart of them
then we see something that makes us
incredibly happy George Lopez as his
character Dio Rudy flying one of the
most famous vehicles in the DC Universe
the bug let's just hope that after the
very inspirational words of wisdom that
Rudy gives Jaime that he doesn't suffer
the same fate as Peter Parker's Uncle
Ben okay can we just can we spare some
uncles please can can we keep some Theos
in this superhero Universe agreed agreed
let's let the man live now Blue Beetle
uses a hammer shaped fist to pound what
looks like an RPG to the ground he stand
in front of some interesting looking
blue energy source in the hallway behind
him I can't really make out what this is
yet but Milagros cries over the body of
someone
maybe a certain adult family member
maybe your father we don't really know
we're very worried she's worried the
home explodes maybe from some of those
drone attacks from cord but as she looks
at the house behind her on the street
doesn't that look like Blue Beetle
crumbled on the street there I'm very
worried could be this I'm horrified
could be I know it could be
but then on to the trailers needle drop
you gotta love this whatever you can
imagine
I can create
nice choice
oh my God I love that initial fling of
the blade from his left hand reminds me
of that T-1000 in Terminator 2 but then
he he's just like no no I can do better
and he slaps his hand together with his
other hand to make that big ass sword
super impractical but you know what
perfect for the character perfect for
the character what a great moment
reminiscent of Power Rangers I think I
think that's the moment of the trailer
and we have finally arrived to the shop
that all Blue Beetle fans are gonna be
going nuts over Ted cord's lab which
includes not just his Blue Beetle suit
but the original Beetle Dan Garrett's
suit as well so a little more comics
history here as we keep going back
through time in 1939 the very first
iteration of the Blue Beetle a character
named Dan Garrett appeared in not DC
Comics not Charlton Comics but Fox
comics and Dan Garrett was originally a
non-powered vigilante kind of like the
Green Hornet but at one point started to
drink a mysterious chemical that gave
him superpowers and thus continuing the
American tradition of superheroes
getting their abilities through steroids
Charlton Comics apparently really bought
the rights to Blue Beetle and eventually
made their own version of Dan Garrett
who debuted during this Silver age of
comics in 1964. this time with a last
name with two T's this Dan Garrett was
an archaeologist who found a mystical
Scarab in Egypt that gave him
superpowers like flight super strength
and the ability to fire energy blasts
that same Scarab that eventually became
Jaime's and was revealed to be not
Supernatural but extraterrestrial in
origin and Charlton Comics also kept Dan
Garrett around as the professor of you
guessed it grad student Ted cord who
like we said first appeared not long
after in 1966 and continued his mentor's
legacy until he met his gruesome end in
2005's countdown to Infinite Crisis in
the pages of DC Comics but now currently
Ted court is also alive in the
mainstream DC Comics universe so we got
all the Beatles y'all lastly we cannot
forget to highlight the hilarious moment
where Uncle Rudy calls Batman a fascist
which can definitely be seen as just a
fun any throwaway line but it could also
be seen as a point of view of how some
non-white communities of the fictional
DC extended Universe might view a
powerful and connected brutally violent
white vigilante with no oversight
branding prison inmates and blowing up
portions of Gotham City if this universe
is still the same one where the dceus
Batman was active for as far back as the
1990s it's always interesting to see how
the normal denizens of superhero
universes feel about their overpowered
protectors so let's maybe not dismiss
Rudy right off the bat he's got some
wisdom we have established this plus
Eric this line has made a lot of real
dumb dummies mad on the internet so I
love it
it's super fun you know the calling
Batman a fascist defends you just chill
oh any Universe characters are allowed
to have different perspectives of
characters without an entire Studio
saying we are endorsing this point of
view but you know what it does feel a
little weird to see Batman fighting
alongside an army of cops in The Dark
Knight Rises like I get it I get it for
that movie it's just weird to watch now
like I wouldn't want to follow those
Victorious cops to a second location
like hey we won now let's go to the
Narrows and make them all pay and I'd be
like make who pay at this point he'd be
like you know you know you know them
I agree and a great Shout Out by DC at
the end of this trailer to some Blue
Beetle Comics if you're interested in
learning more about Jaime you should go
check out Infinite Crisis Blue Beetle
Jaime Reyes book one which is a great
collection of some of his earliest
comics and Blue Beetle graduation day
issues one through five which are out
now yep yep yep now that was everything
that you might have missed in this Blue
Beetle trailer Hector I'm super pumped
for this movie I'm so excited I think
it's gonna be a blast me too it looks
like it's so much fun in the best
absolute possible way that we can
imagine cannot wait to watch it with all
of my friends in August in August August
can't come soon enough now a reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive into support this growing Network
by grabbing some merch at nerdrive.shop
follow me at eavos follow Hector and
Hector is funny follow me rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching everyone bye
[Music]
thank you